que marine est calme est juriste et
porte-parole du collectif hors de
question opposé au projet montagne d'or
michael bay bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france cette décision était
attendue depuis le début du mois de
décembre c'est une surprise pour vous
malheureusement non il s'agit pas d'une
surprise étant donné que le gouvernement
à totalement délaissé finalement ce
procès c'était la politique de la chaise
vide et face à cela évidemment nous
attendions à ce que la justice tranche
en faveur de la compagnie montagne dont
certains accusent l'état de ne pas avoir
suffisamment défendu sa position face à
la justice
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
exactement ça c'est que pour vous
rappeler un petit peu les faits le 4
décembre dernier devant brut médias
emmanuel macron annonçait que il avait
tout fait pour arrêter le projet
montagne d'or disait que justement
contrairement aux autres il avait laissé
traîner le dossier qu'ils avaient arrêté
le projet c'était aussi ce qui avait été
annoncé en mai 2010 neuf que le projet
n'était définitivement abandonnée en
raison de l'incompatibilité avec les
exigences environnementales de la france
hélas malgré tout on voit qu'en fait le
gouvernement non seulement n'a pas
refusé donc là prolongement de la
concession bien mais en plus totalement
délaissé les arguments juridiques il
aurait pu saisir pour tout simplement
demandé le rejet de la demande de la
compagnie minière et il ne l'a pas fait
et donc en conséquence de considérons
que l'état a failli dans cette
obligation c'est encore une carence de
plus dans ce dossier et on voit bien
qu'en fait il ya un double discours
entre les annonces qui disent que le
gouvernement abandonne le projet et puis
la réalité dans les zac il n'y a
absolument rien eu qui a permis
l'abandon de ce projet sur le terrain et
donc forcément on repart dans un mauvais
cycle est ce que nous demandons c'est
évidemment que l'état fasse appel de
cette décision et se saisit
sérieusement des arguments qui peuvent
être pointées dans ce dossier justement
vous pointez du doigt les solutions
qu'il reste quels sont les recours qui
reste aux opposants à ce projet minier
alors déjà il faut régler l'état comme
disait fasse un appel de cette décision
pour que enfin on puisse proposer les
arguments juridiques qui soit cohérent
et dans un deuxième temps sur le terrain
la mobilisation n'a pas faibli le
collectif hors de question ne s'est
jamais laissé duper par les annonces du
gouvernement et à rester mobilisés
pendant tous ces mois qui ont suivi
l'annoncé de mai 2019
et s'il le faut nous retournerons dans
la rue et nous re manifesterons notre
opposition au projet pour obtenir
l'abandon définitif ce projet ne passera
pas il est absolument hors de question
qu'ils voient le jour sur le territoire
ni sous cette forme ou sous une autre
puisque la mine industrielle quoi qu'il
arrive est incompatible avec les
exigences en matière de protection du
climat et de la biodiversité et à
l'heure actuelle il n'ya pas encore
d'études d'impact qui a été publié et il
n'y a pas encore d'autorisation
d'ouverture de travaux et l'autorisation
d'ouverture de travaux quoi qu'il arrive
si on devait en arriver là nous la
contesterons évidemment vous pourriez
rapidement nous rappeler les enjeux
environnementaux autour de
l'exploitation de cette fameuse montagne
d'or alors déjà il s'agit d'un projet
qui aura un impact climatique énorme
puisque en termes de d'impact
on estime à environ 50 % des émissions
totales de la guyane en plus à un impact
extrêmement fort en terme de
biodiversité puisque la zone dans
laquelle est prévu le projet se situe
entre 2 réserve biologique intégrale
donc dans des espaces où en fait il n'y
avait plus d'une centaine d'espèces
protégées
il est sous ma maman censés être
protégés parce portuaire de biodiversité
qui l'entourent en plus de ça il
faudrait tracer une route à travers la
corrèze qui non seulement perturberait
la biodiversité mais en plus traire un
chemin beaucoup plus facile d'accès aux
orpailleurs illégaux qui a encore un
autre fléau sur ce territoire
et il faut savoir que l'impact a eu un
impact cela en fait la mine pardon a un
impact en matière de consommation de
l'eau de l'eau
de 470 milles litres d'eau par heure
c'est absolument pas compatible avec la
préservation des écosystèmes de ce
territoire est donc évidemment mis
bout-à-bout l'ensemble de ces raisons
écologiques fait que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter ce projet merci beaucoup marine
calme et d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes juriste et
porte-parole du collectif hors de
question